[Musica]
a novembre 2019 internazionale titolava
i padroni del clima banche assicurazioni
fondi di investimento
ecco chi potrebbe fermare la crisi
climatica
se solo volesse ma allora la finanza può
davvero cambiare il mondo in meglio e
soprattutto noi abbiamo un potere da
mesi giovani in tutto il mondo scendono
in piazza per far sentire la loro voce
stanno chiedendo di agire
all'istituzione urgentemente per
rallentare le emissioni che incidono sui
cambiamenti climatici a un ritmo tale da
rendere addirittura in dubbio la
sopravvivenza sulla terra molte persone
anche noi stiamo acquisendo
consapevolezza di quelli che sono gli
effetti di un modello produttivo e
industriale in cui viviamo da decenni ma
si sa i cambiamenti culturali e politici
sono lenti nel produrre risultati e se
ci fosse un'altra leva che funziona
rapidamente a livello globale i leader
politici non sono gli unici potenti del
pianeta
sì perché tutti coloro che controllano
la circolazione della maggior parte dei
soldi hanno un enorme potere e
potrebbero agire
nell'arco di pochi mesi persino poche
ore non anni o decenni
forse esiste un modo per fermare
l'emissione di carbonio nell'atmosfera
interrompere il flusso di denaro che va
sì verso il carbone verso il gas verso
il petrolio
noi abbiamo un potere possiamo scendere
in piazza e far sentire la nostra voce
possiamo far aumentare la pressione
mediatica e possiamo fare un'altra cosa
possiamo cambiare banca possano togliere
le risorse da coloro che investono nella
crisi climatica che la promuovono e far
gestire i nostri risparmi
invece a chi finanzia la produzione di
energia da fonti rinnovabili
la rigenerazione degli ecosistemi la
tutela dell'ambiente e tutti noi anche
se siamo piccoli se siamo tanti
possiamo far cambiare idea anche ai
grandi
si è anche rapidamente pensate sia
un'utopia vero proviamo a capire
assicurazioni generali
forse la conoscete assicurazioni
generali ha deliberato l'uscita dagli
investimenti e dalle assicurazioni nel
settore carbonifero perché su pressione
dei soci
pensate se i grandi player della finanza
decidessero e reputazione
forse anche per perdita di business
forse per pressione di disinvestire
l'effetto sarebbe globale sarebbe
importante
pensate addirittura se 5 tra manager
delle grandi banche decidessero di
allocare diversamente anche solo 5 10
per cento degli investimenti loro non
rischierebbero nulla
e l'impatto sulla finanza globale
sarebbe veramente enorme
ecco allora perché ciascuna e ciascuno
di noi è essenziale
noi non siamo indifferenti per il
sistema
noi abbiamo un potere e se ci mettiamo
assieme abbiamo molto potere
sì possiamo pretendere che con i nostri
soldi si investa in quei progetti che
condividono i nostri stessi valori
proprio da queste fondamenta trent'anni
fa sono nate le banche etiche
alternative quelle che con i soldi dei
risparmiatori e degli investitori
finanziano tutte quelle imprese poco
inquinanti pulite che tutelano i
lavoratori e tutelano le comunità che
vivono attorno alle imprese
esiste anche un alleanza riunisce 55
istituzioni finanziarie di tutto il
mondo che nel finanziare le imprese
mettono al primo posto la tutela
dell'ambiente e allo stesso posto
mettono la tutela dei diritti umani
queste banche etiche oggi servono 50
milioni di clienti e gestiscono
risparmio per 200 miliardi di dollari
pensate a quella a quale potenza
potremmo dare a questo tipo di finanza
però forse ve ne siete accorti anche voi
ultimamente forse per conquistare nuove
fasce di mercato si perché ci sono
quelle persone attente alle conseguenze
sociali e ambientali delle proprie
scelte di consumo e di risparmio
siamo veramente invasi da un sacco di
pubblicità di grandi banche e fondi
d'investimento che dicono noi
siamo sostenibili bene è importante
e importante che finalmente la grande
finanza apra gli occhi però noi non
siamo ingenui vero ci dice qualcosa ci
ricordiamo gli accordi di parigi sul
clima per ridurla co2 2016 2018
ecco secondo lana un'analisi di una rete
internazionale bank trek
nei tre anni da questi accordi 33 tra i
maggiori gruppi bancari al mondo hanno
fornito 1.900 miliardi di dollari di
prestiti alle fonti fossili e questa
cifra cresce ogni anno 600 miliardi sono
stati destinati alle 100 imprese che in
modo più aggressivo investono il
combustibili fossili
ma allora che cosa sta accadendo sta
accadendo che 16 di quei 33 gruppi
bancari erano anche firmatari dei
principi for responsible 20 delle
nazioni unite
insomma esistono grandi banche che fanno
un sacco di promesse e poi accade così
poco beh allora la finanza cosa serve la
finanza serve a tutti noi però deve
essere messa a servizio del benessere
delle persone deve escludere ogni
finanziamento alle fonti fossili
sì sì ma anche al gioco d'azzardo sì
però anche al settore delle armi ea
tutte le altre attività nocive
noi vorremmo che la nostra banca con i
nostri pochi sudati risparmi facesse
affari con chi produce armi che uccidono
milioni di persone tutti di noi
probabilmente non vorrebbero che questo
avvenisse
però quando andiamo in banca e abbiamo
un conto corrente compriamo un
obbligazione
facciamo un piccolo investimento
sappiamo che cosa accade ai nostri soldi
raramente sappiamo che cosa fa la banca
con i nostri soldi
purtroppo in italia esiste una fiorente
industria che è quella degli armamenti e
molte banche italiane finanziano e fanno
profitti con chi fabbrica e produce e
commercializza armi armi che poi vengono
utilizzate nelle guerre come lo yemen
come quella contro i curdi e la cosa
possiamo fare possiamo scegliere
possiamo scegliere una finanza che ci
garantisce che i nostri soldi non
verranno mai utilizzati per business
lesivi del pianeta e dei diritti delle
persone e possiamo scegliere che i
nostri soldi vengano utilizzati per
finanziare invece quali attività
sì proprio quelle quelle dell'energia da
fonti rinnovabili o anche l'agricoltura
biologica si il turismo responsabile
ma anche tutti i progetti culturali o
forse sì anche gli asili nido o il
progetto di integrazione per migranti ma
anche sia anche l'inserimento lavorativo
dei disabili
e sì anche l'uso sociale dei beni
liberati alle mafie allora noi che cosa
possiamo fare per fermare questa finanza
speculativa
ognuno deve fare la sua parte
ognuno di noi può fare qualcosa
ci siamo detti che possiamo cambiare
banca possiamo chiedere più trasparenza
però dobbiamo fare anche un'altra cosa
dobbiamo dare un segnale inequivocabile
alla nostra politica
questa finanza non funziona bisogna
cambiare e dobbiamo essere noi i primi a
obbligare i nostri stati a fermare la
spettanza la finanza speculativa
in media ci dicono sempre non ci sono
soldi per le scuole non ci sono soldi
per la sanità non ci sono soldi per il
territorio
eppure non ci sono mai stati così tanti
soldi in circolazione come oggi solo che
sono chiusi in un circuito speculativo
che va dove fa aumentare le risorse
della parte più ricca della popolazione
secondo il financial times che non è
proprio un giornale movimentista ogni
anno in media a livello globale solo sui
derivati si muovono 3000 trilioni di
dollari
non riesco neanche a pronunciarla una
cifra così
eppure è pari a 50 volte il prodotto
interno lordo globale un p che l'ocse
stima in 60 trilioni di dollari
nell'ora che fare
dobbiamo prendere le risorse e
orientarle verso la riconversione green
delle nostre economie a tutela dei
lavoratori a tutela delle persone più
fragili
non basta dire green new deal
bisogna agire ma sentite e se facessimo
pagare la riconversione ecologica a chi
in questi anni ha fatto più profitti a
spese dell'ambiente e delle persone che
ne dite chi
la grande finanza speculativa e vi
faccio una proposta si chiama tassa per
la riconversione ecologica o tassa per
la riconversione finanziaria l'obiettivo
lo stesso esiste un meccanismo fiscale
efficace per inserirsi nel mercato e
vendere meno convenienti più costose
proprio quelle operazioni che fanno male
allo sviluppo sociale e umano quali i
derivati le operazioni ad alta frequenza
se sì proprio quelle quelle che gli
speculatori finanziari più aggressivi
utilizzano per comprare vendere lo
stesso titolo migliaia di volte in un
secondo perché poi speculano sulle
oscillazioni di prezzo
il tutto in un click
e arrivato il momento di fare delle
scelte scelte forti scelte strutturali e
dire no alla finanza speculativa e dire
sì sì a quegli investimenti e quei
finanziamenti che danno gambe
all'economia reale sia quell'economia
che ha un impatto sociale e ambientale e
tutti noi cosa possiamo fare possiamo
scegliere possiamo scegliere di
consumare meno e meglio possiamo
scegliere di avere cura e rispetto del
nostro pianeta
possiamo scegliere di avere rispetto e
cura delle nostre comunità e possiamo
scegliere quale finanza per il futuro
possiamo chiedere alle nostre banche
cosa fanno con i nostri soldi possiamo
chiedere trasparenza possiamo obbligare
i nostri stati affermare la finanza
speculativa perché perché la finanza
siamo noi siamo noi con le piccole
scelte di ogni giorno di ogni giorno con
i nostri piccoli risparmi ai nostri
piccoli investimenti
il momento giusto per cambiare e oggi
[Musica]